ladies and gentlemen we've probably woke
up to the Hollywood Walk of Fame
Christina Applegate
[Applause]
hi my lovers oh you're all so gorgeous
every single one of you
wow
I love you guys so much um Katie's gonna
have to stand up here with me because oh
what did I win did I win a million
dollars better what did I win it's
better than that what
okay well we're gonna ship them disabled
lady
right here on behalf of the Hollywood
Chamber of Commerce we now declare today
Christina Applegate and Holly because
she's having a day everyone
let me try that one more time we now
declare today Christina Applegate day in
Hollywood
that's better than a million dollars I
think I like that but I'd also like a
couple million dollars because it's not
sorry it's now time to hear from our
honoree oh sorry was I supposed to be
sitting this whole time no no no it's
your day okay it's my pleasure to
present to You Christina Applegate
um thank you Lupita
it's gonna be here this is gonna be here
pretend I'm not here so Katie to like
steal the Thunder like yeah I'm kidding
you know I love you um thank you Lupita
thank you to the Hollywood Chamber of
Commerce for this incredible
stuff
um I I I've had a really interesting
life but the life started as being a
little girl
waiting in line to see the first Star
Wars on this very Street at that very
theater and looking at these things
going who are these people what did they
do did they do something right did they
do something wrong whatever it is I want
one
I effing want one
and I was five years old
so um this day means more to me than you
could possibly imagine
um I I can't stand for too long so I'm
gonna um thank the people that I really
need to thank uh first of all to my my
family who has spoken here today you are
you
um you are my everything
I love that I started
with you two and ended with you too
and I thank you so much from the bottom
of my heart you are You Are My People
you are my loves
to Amanda birth yes thank you um
to Rick hertzman who um 20 years ago uh
was calling me and I was driving on
Mulholland and I'm like oh that that
damn agent from CA is calling again
trying to get my business and
I was like forget it I'll pull over I'll
pull over on Mulholland and I talk to
you Rick kurtzman
and we've been together for 20 plus
years and you were
the best of the best uh to Eric cransler
who came in and swooped in and took over
my life after coming back from New York
you are one of the kindest most
beautiful human beings I've ever known
in my life and I'm so blessed to have
both of you to Amy Van Iden who lives in
Tennessee
still has me as a client
um you are my love
um and I I love you and I I'm so
protected by you to Steve Warren to we
you guys came into my life and you take
such good care of me and I'm so I was so
pleased that I've had this group of
people for 20 plus years
um
people don't do that my mom used to say
it's like changing ages it's like
changing um
deck chairs on the Titanic but
um
I've stuck with mine
so I guess we're going down all together
um
to my Lindsay Maya dear my people
most of all to my family I don't say
that I have friends
I have family these people take care of
me they take care of me every day of my
life and without them I don't know what
I would do and lastly the most
the most important
person in this world is my daughter
you are
so much more
you are so much more than even you know
you are so beautiful and kind and loving
and smart and interesting and I am
blessed every day that I get to wake up
and take you to your school and do what
I have you're my everything thank you
for standing beside me through all of
this oh by the way I have a disease
um anyway
um
did you not notice
I'm not even wearing shoes
anywho you're supposed to laugh at that
anyway
um to my beautiful family to my Marlin
my more time to my look I can't Mandy
feral Rob I can't wait there's too many
of you over there okay thank you so much
this is an incredible honor
[Applause]
[Music]